I just like to play this clip and get
your reaction to this clip and you tell
me what you think
statements like this from the former CIA
director how they affected the
conversation around these issues why
won't the president confront Vladimir
Putin why won't he read the cards and
say the things that you say need to be
said to Vladimir Putin do you believe he
is somehow in debt to the president of
Russia I think he's afraid of the
president of Russia why um well I think
one can speculate as to why that the
Russians may have something on him
personally that they could always roll
out and make his life more difficult I
have two reactions and I I will get to
the disinformation thing in a second but
the first thing I'll say to come back to
the question of the ruling party is that
the the sort of tricked understanding
how the ruling party operates in America
is that
it is because it is uh run by the
perhaps the most untalented incompetent
group of people ever assembled in the
country's history that they have
insisted on such a
um insisted on these coercive and
monopolistic tactics for controlling the
government I mean I think Brennan is a
um but by the the sort of the standard
measures of what you would expect from
the nation's intelligence Chief
phenomenally untalented and
unaccomplished where he has excelled is
as a party hack you know as a as a a
Soviet or Chinese style party hack and
the claim that he is making there which
is that Donald Trump is controlled by or
indebted to or or somehow under the
thumb of Vladimir Putin and therefore by
extension the Russian Security Services
is a claim that he is in many senses
singularly responsible for entering into
the official record of American politics
when in one of his last acts the CIA
chief he basically
singularly orchestrated what was known
as the ICA the intelligence Community
assessment so this was the I believe it
came out in January 2017 but it was the
first the seminal
intelligence Community assessment which
declared that not only did Putin
interfere in the 2016 election but that
he had a preference for Donald Trump
what we later found out through
Classified house testimony
um that you know people who had been
privy to it spoke about was that rather
than being a a statement on representing
the opinion of the 17 different
intelligence agencies which is what an
ICA is supposed to be a consensus
statement in other words that in fact
Brennan himself had hand-picked a group
of analysts and had personally uh led
the drafting of the ICA that declared
that Putin had a preference for Trump
and that in doing so he had excluded the
analysis from Russia experts who not
only didn't find that credible but who
said that no in fact as Russia experts
they had found that Putin's preference
was actually for Hillary Clinton because
uh Putin considered her the more
predictable candidate not that there was
any nefarious relationship with Clinton
but simply that in ways that are quite
easy to understand that he he wanted the
sort of stock neoliberal candidate
because he could guess what move she was
going to make and so that that was
Brennan's doing
um Brennan you know the fact that he
left the CIA to immediately become a
MSNBC analyst tells you a lot both about
Brennan and about MSNBC and the
relationship between the media and the
intelligent agencies and the media here
is simply providing the amplification
system
for narratives that are originating
elsewhere you know that's why I I talk
about the weakness of the media in
relation to these other members of the
counter disinformation complex not
because the media doesn't play a
critical role in amplifying and
enforcing these narratives but because
it doesn't generate these narratives on
its own and therefore it's not in charge
of their final Direction and orientation
so I may uh just I I would like to point
out that morning Joe is kind of like the
Max's Kansas City or The Studio 54 of
the ruling party right this is It's you
know not accidental that this happened
and on MSNBC and on NBC News and things
like that so when you are when you
observe this fact pattern uh around John
Brennan and see that he he discarded
certain information and privileged other
information is is making these very
pointed well not pointed but let's say
very broad speculation on National
Television is your analysis that this is
a kind of tunnel vision
um that he can he he believes this or
that this actually is something more
nefarious that this is that it that he's
trying to actually be a disinformation
purveyor
well two things so one I would never
accuse somebody of being a
disinformation purveyor because I don't
use the term in that way I think the
term is deliberately obscuritanist and
it's an Espionage term and I'm I'm not
in the business of Espionage so I'm not
accusing anybody of disinformation I
think I think they get things wrong or
they get them right
um
I look I don't see any reason to try and
impute motive here I think that the the
facts of the case speak for themselves
what we know about The Crafting of the
ICA is that Brennan omitted contrary
analysis and you should people should go
back and read that ICA from 2017 when I
when I talk about how untalented he is
you know I think sometimes the documents
speak louder than these
characterizations go read the ICA it it
establishes nothing it proves nothing
it's not well argued it has a 12-page
appendix drawing on Russia Today
articles from 2012. it's like a a shoddy
nomenclatura kind of document that is a
sort of placeholder Brennan's
willingness to or or interest in
transitioning from the CIA to talking
ahead on on MSNBC to signatory to the
false National Security official little
documents claiming that the hunter Biden
laptops were disinformation
um speaks for itself that was reasons
live stream with Jacob Siegel if you
liked it and want to hear the whole
thing go here if you want to listen to
another excerpt go here and come back
every Thursday at 1 pm eastern time for
Zach wise Miller and I's reason live
stream